I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi. I don't know, you can't start like that. Why? off-slates. Hi.
I don't know, you can't start like that. Why? I meant foul mood. I meant a foul mood. And the job now that you have ahead of yourself, Angela, is that you have to remove me during this podcast. I am going to remove you, don't you worry. There's some really good stuff.
I am actually excited about the stuff I have to share today. It's good. Good. Today, we're talking about after hours, it is season eight, episode 16, written by Halstead Sullivan and Warren Lieberstein and directed by Brian Baumgartner. I know, how fun was that?
A cast member. Do you want a summary or do I need to tell people why I'm in a fall mood? I think you should probably share why you're in a fall mood. Get it out of the way, get rid of it. Okay. It's just one of those things. I've had two bad sleeps in a row.
No. And last night I really set myself up for a good sleep. I took a melatonin. I went to bed when the kids went to bed. I was like, I've got nine hours ahead of me of sleeping bliss. Great. And then, at midnight, I don't know, Maggie saw something
out the window and she started barking and it woke me up. And then I was awake for like an hour and a half. And I'm in a bad mood because of it. That's it. That's very simple. When I don't get sleep, I get real cranky and I'm on two bad mood because of it. That's it. That's very simple. When I don't get sleep, I get real cranky and I'm on two nights of not good sleep. Is there a term for that?
You know, like hangry is when you're hungry and angry. Am I sleep deprived? Dree, gree, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, slangry, slangry. Okay. All right. You're already making me laugh, so this is good. Moving on, here is your summary.
In telehassy, Dwight and Todd Packer compete for the VP position of special projects by attempting to seduce Nelly. Also, Jim feels uncomfortable with Kathy's behavior toward him. Um, yeah. I have a lot to say. I have so many thoughts. All right. Finally, the group back in Scranton picks up the slack from the Florida group.
They have to stay late, but things turn awkward when Val's boyfriend shows up and confronts Darryl about some text messages he sent to Val. Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. Fastback number one, our cast member Brian Baumgartner was director. But open, open, open. Yes, I loved Brian as director. He had such a great energy.
He comes into a room with so much charisma, the cast and crew loved him. And he shines. You could tell he was having the best time and cast and crew loved him. And he shines. You could tell he was having the best time and was excited to be there, and that energy was contagious. Well, we got to trade messages with the writers of this episode, Warnley-Berstein,
and Halstead Sullivan, and they both had very nice things to say about Brian as a director. Warn said that Brian was very well-liked by the cast and crew, like you said, Ange, and he did a really great job of setting up shots. In fact, I have a couple of really fun things to share later that were kind of more elaborate than anything we've ever done before. That Brian thought of. I have a guess as one. Yeah, I'm gonna hold on to it. Okay, hold on to it. But Warren said the thing, Brian, really excelled at was bringing out a real sense of fun,
particularly between John and Rain, like in the scene where Dwight asked him if the bed bug was smug. That's what I was thinking of. I was just starting to say it. And Warren thought maybe it was because those three had a really good real-life friendship. So they had a shorthand.
Well, yeah, you know, almost every day for lunch, you guys, the three of them would meet and John's trailer and play Madden football. And we could hear them while we were trying to have lunch. Yeah. In my trailer. They hung out a lot. You know, Halstead also said that Brian was great and he said there was kind of a cool
coincidence because Halstead, Brian, and Ed all went to the same high school. I didn't know that. I mean, I knew about Brian and Ed, but I didn't know Halstead, Brian, and Ed all went to the same high school. I didn't know that. I mean, I knew about Brian and Ed, but I didn't know Halstead went there, too. Yeah, I mean, not at the same time. You know, he said Ed and Brian were younger than him, but they all went to Westminster in Atlanta, and they took a photo for their alumni together on set.
I love that. Halstead said to say, go Wildcats. Okay, go Wildcats. Go Wildcats. Moving on to fast say go wild cats. Okay, go wild cats. Go wild cats. Moving on to FastFact number two, I think we need to talk about Jerry Minor as Val's boyfriend Brandon. I mean, Jenna, when I rewatched those conference room scenes, right? We could not keep it together. I see us breaking. I see, my character is like smiling in a few places. Like, what is happening?
He was so great. I have known Jerry for a very, very long time. We have the same manager. That's right. So we were often doing showcases together. In fact, like acting like scenes, like when you're trying to get representation, like you're trying to get an agent or a manager,
you'll put together like a little group of actors and you'll do like a one act play. And then you invite a bunch of industry people to come see it in hopes of getting wrapped. Yes, I did something like this, but we did like a vignette of scenes, like little scenes. Yes, I've done that too. So you did that with Jerry?
Yes, he was already wrapped by Naomi Odin Kirk, as was this actor Jim Zulovec, and they needed an actress to play a role, and like a friend of a friend recommended me, and I ended up doing this showcase with them. How fun! And then Naomi ended up representing me, which was so crazy, but yeah.
I kinda miss those days a little bit, just getting to do a group of scenes with great actors on stage. It's so fun. So fun. Did I do an actor nerd out moment? I think you just had an actor nerd out moment and I love it. Well, you guys might recognize Jerry from a gazillion thing. Yeah. Mr. Show, the Daily Show, SNL, Eastbound and Down,
and you know, he actually has a bunch of office connections. He was an anchor man with Steve. He actually auditioned to be Jim on the office. I did not know that. Mm-hmm. Oh, I didn't know that. He also knows Craig really well. Yes.
They did, we talked about this when we were talking with Craig, that he did that very famous song, somebody's f***ing my lady. Yes, so funny. It was so much fun to have him on set and the rapport between Craig and Jerry, it just made those scenes so good. And you know, he has more office connections
since he left the show. He did the sex lives of college girls, which is Mindy's show. He was a recurring character on Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt with Ellie. He was in Superstore, which is writer, Justin Spitzer's show. And most recently, he's been a recurring character on Abbott Elementary, which is executive produced by Randall Einhorn. Right. And Angel, I know you have your own connection to Jerry.
I do. I mean, I met Jerry years ago through Improvillinpic, but then we ended up on Hot Wives of Orlando together. That job was so much fun. For those of you guys who aren't familiar, it was a show that parodied the Real Housewives and it followed seven women in Orlando, Florida. The cast was Kristen Shaw, Kasey Wilson, Timberley Hill, Andrea Savage, Danielle Schneider,
and Donna Fineglass-Furman. It was the funniest group of women all in one space together. And Jerry played Rodney, Feifei's cheating husband. And you know he crushed it. And also Warren and Hallstedt had worked with Jerry on a show they wrote on called Carpoolers. So they were already huge fans, and Warren said they both felt super lucky that Jerry was available to play Val's boyfriend.
Can you guys tell that we just love Jerry Minor? Yeah. I mean, he's just one of those, like, what would you call them? He's an actor where you just, is that like a clutch? A clutch in a clutch? Oh, like a sports. What is that? You just know they're gonna come in
and they're just gonna crush it. Yeah, that's him. He's a clutch. I don't think that's the right way to use it. In a clutch. In a clutch. So I'm sorry. a clutch anyway you guys our sports preferences are horrible someone is groaning right now as they listen but yes Jerry Minor with that clutch we think player is the
word yeah okay let's move on to fast fact number, it's the gym and Kathy controversy. I am positive without you telling me that there was a fan mail flurry. There sure was, because I have a few bulls*** cards I'm ready to play. Oh, get them ready. I mean, you're going to have a stack of them. So the main question we got was this, people wrote in and said, there is a story going around on the internet saying that the writers originally intended for Jim to have an affair with Kathy. No. Yeah, no.
But that John Krasinski was so heavily against this idea that he convinced the writing staff to change their minds about the storyline. Is this true? Well, you would have never gone for that either. Yeah, no, that, no. We can clear this up right now. Jim was never going to have an affair with or hook up with Kathy. However, there's a however, there were things about the proposed storyline that did bump me and John.
Here's how it all went down. So after we filmed Kathy's phone call at the end of special project, you know where she's like talking to her friend and it becomes clear that she's gonna go after Jim and tell her how she, it comes out of the blue. I don't know where. Well, that was a total record scratch for me and John.
We kind of immediately went into Paul's office and we were like, well, what, well, what? Yeah, we were exactly really, where is this going? We said there is no way that Jim can hook up with Kathy. And Paul was like, that is not part of our plan. I promise you. Okay, no, that's part of her plan. That's Kathy's plan.
Jim is not in that plan. And I actually checked with Warren and Hallstead who wrote this episode and they confirmed that it was never part of the plan. And lady, don't ask me how I have it, but I have the original Goldilocks outline for this episode. You know why? Why? Because you're my best friend and we're both digital hoarders. You say it's really just me but you have some odd stuff you hold on to. Now you hold on to things almost a little bit more intentionally whereas mine is just like you know crazy clutter. Yeah. Well I did collect
things that had to do with Jim and Pam. Yes. And what the Goldilocks was, it was the kind of very first story outline for every script. Right. Before they went off and wrote anything. Exactly. This was what the writers could use when they went to write the script. And it was based on everything that had been pitched. And this document had to be approved by the producers. There is nothing in the Goldilocks about Jim
hooking up with Kathy for this episode. So this is even more more proof. More a proof. Yes. When I talked to Warren about it, he said that the character of Kathy was always meant to be a kind of like provocateur. You know, you think about when she was introduced, Pam is really bothered that Jim won't admit that she's objectively attractive, right? But it was never pitched or it was never the intention that Jim would have any romantic feelings toward Kathy. It was always kind of understood by the writers that that was off limits. However, another, however, in the very first drafts of this script,
there was a lot more kind of teasing of the audience. Like, will he? Like, is he being charned by her? Is he flirting back with her? Or is he just being a nice guy? Like in the version you see here, he is so clearly uncomfortable and is a giant no every time she does something. But in the original script, there was a little bit more like repartee.
And John and I got to read that and it really bumped us. We felt like even walking that line was a betrayal and we did not want that for Jim and Pam's relationship. You know, the producer said that the idea was that they were putting temptation in front of Jim to show how committed he was to Pam. Those teases were more to create tension for the audience than they were to imply that Jim would ever do anything. But because we complained, they made some tweaks
to make sure that it felt like this was 100% driven by a Kathy, and there would be no mixed signals from Jim. Like, we didn't want there to be anything where it was like, you could say, well, Jim, you shouldn't have laughed with her in that moment, or you shouldn't have whispered in her ear during that conference room scene.
Like, of course she's getting the wrong idea. Those are examples of the little things that she could have taken the wrong way. Right. So the shooting draft of this script also included a scene where Pam calls Jim's hotel room on speakerphone and Kathy answers the phone. Oh, I know. Yes.
We shot it. It was written that Pam is really insecure about this. And even though it was really clear from Jim's side that he's really uncomfortable with Kathy in the room, Pam can't see that. So I didn't like that scene. I didn't like that Pam would become so easily insecure because again, I felt like that pointed to a bigger issue in the marriage.
And I asked them like, how is that gonna get resolved? Like is Pam ever gonna tell Jim her feelings? Yeah, what's the long-term ripple effect of that moment? And there wasn't really an answer. They were like, oh, it's not an arc, don't worry. And I'm like, no, no, but if you're gonna bring it up, it's, we should out there. It's out there.
So, yeah. Well, I watched that scene, because it's in deleted scenes. And, you know, there's more to it. There's more to the phone call. Yeah, I mean, some of that was a late night writing scramble. I was gonna bring it up kind of like where it would happen in the breakdown.
So we should definitely talk more about it. I mean, I still have more to say. Well, there's a lot to discuss, and I'm gonna need to play that clip when we get to it. But I think we should take a break because when we come back, we have our very favorite cold open as Pam and Angela. It really is.
I'm already in kind of a better mood, and now the fact that we get to talk about that cold open, I think it's gonna be the medicine I need. Yay, no more slangry. We are back. This cold open starts with Pam walking over to accounting. She shows Angela a photo of baby Philip wearing the booties that Angela bought for Philip. Yes, right? Very nice to learn that Angela did that. Right.
And it seems like a nice moment. There was an extra line to this little couplet. Jenna, I read it in the shooting draft last night and I started laughing. I laughed out loud. It is such a small, it's only one sentence, but it cracks me up. Pam says, Hey, Angela, I want to see a picture of Philip wearing those booties you gave us. Angela says, so cute. Do you have any pictures of them without Philip? Oh, it's so snarky. Oh my God. But that line got edited out. It needed to because in this moment, they're bonding. Yes, they need to bond because then it sets up
this great runner between Angela Oscar and Pam. Yes. Where they take turns taking sides. Yes. So after Pam and Angela bond over their booty photo, Yeah. Booty meaning on their feet. Baby booties.
Baby booties. Oscar wants to share a photo of his dog, Gerald, wearing rain galoshes. I mean, now that Gerald has them, he can't stop wearing them. He loves them. Pam and Angela share a look. Then they have a talking head where they're like, Oscar thinks that having a dog is the same as having a baby. So they're kind of like ganging up on that person who thinks having a pet is the same
as having a kid. But then we're going to go into the kitchen where Oscars going to ask Pam and Angela if their babies are crawling yet. And Pam is like, no, you know, Philip is only three months old. It's too early for that. Angela insists her baby is crawling. She's like, really? My baby Phillips crawling. So then Pam and Oscar share a look. They're like, Angela is such a liar. And then Oscar's gonna complain about his lack of sleep
due to crate training. And Pam is gonna have to one up him and say, oh, you know what? Imagine having two. Right. I've got two kids, two sleep schedules. And now Angela and Oscar are gonna share a look. And then they have a talking head, but they're like, listen, no one said you need to have
two. We don't need more Pam and Jim T&A out there. So now they bond over that. Yes. Finally, Andy's gonna come in the kitchen because he wants everyone to see a picture of his brother's new sailboat because you know what? There is nothing harder than taking care of a boat. Nothing!
Now that three of them really share a look, because come on. I mean, unbelievable. Unbeat, leave, up, ball. Oh, lady, we got so many fan questions about this cold open. Samantha A from Florida said, was Oscars unbeatily bubble scripted in the cold open? I need to know everything about this moment
is my favorite office line in the whole series. Oh Samantha, we have so much to share. So this cold open hit close to home. Warren and Hallstead shared with us the inspiration for it. Warren said that when they wrote this in 2011, he had a young daughter. You guys know, Makito is a bell. Yeah. And Hallstead shared he had just gotten a new puppy named Parker. They said this back and forth about raising a child and raising a puppy stemmed from their actual lives and was probably a source of contention
between the two of them. And then Halstead made the mistake of saying in the writer's room that having a puppy can be just like having a kid with the loss of sleep, et cetera. And Halstead didn't have any children. And immediately everyone in the room who had kids, including Warren jumped in and was like, no, no, no, no, no. And then this writer's room debate made its way
在他们两个之间。然后霍尔斯特德在编剧室里犯了个错误，说养一只小狗就像养一个小孩一样，会面临睡眠不足等等。而霍尔斯特德并没有孩子。房间里所有有孩子的人，包括沃伦在内，立刻插话道，不，不，不，不，不。然后这个编剧室的争论就被写进了
into the show. Hostot said since Angela and Pam both had kids, they used Oscar's dog Gerald to make the bit work. And then of course they heightened it and heightened it and capped it off with all of them teaming up against Andy. I thought this cold open was so relatable. I feel like I've been in these conversations.
剧集里。霍斯托特说，既然安吉拉和潘都有孩子，他们就用了奥斯卡的狗杰拉尔德来让这个桥段行得通。然后当然，他们不断地夸张、再夸张，最后以他们所有人联合起来对抗安迪作结。我觉得这个开场白太有共鸣了。我觉得我也经历过这些对话。
Oh yeah. Right? If you have one kid, then you have that friend that has two. But if you have two kids, you know someone who has four. Or if you have one kid, you know someone who has twins. And, or what if you're a blended family? Do you realize how complicated that is? Yes, I do.
哦，是的。对吧？如果你有一个孩子，你就会认识那个有两个孩子的朋。但如果你有两个孩子，你就会认识一个有四个孩子的人。或者如果你有一个孩子，你认识一个有双胞胎的人。而且，或者如果你是一个重组家庭呢？你知道这有多复杂吗？是的，我知道。
Yes. So it's like the subtle, sometimes one upmanship of your family, what would you call it? Dynamic. I would also say I do have friends, and I love them dearly, that their babies are their fur babies. And I know how special that is.
是的。所以这就像是关于你家庭的微妙的、有时是一决高下的，你管这叫什么？动态。我还要说，我确实有朋友，我非常爱他们，他们的宝宝是他们的毛孩子。我知道这有多特别。
I had on me. I know. It was my fur baby for a long time. And so I have gotten the Christmas card of just the dogs on the front. I love them. I do too. I hang them up. Yes.
我曾经也有过。我知道。它当了很久我的毛孩子。所以我收到过只有狗狗照片正面的圣诞贺卡。我太喜欢了。我也是。我把它们挂起来。是的。
I do feel like I've been in these conversations. Well, Samantha, I also want to tell you and answer to your question that the long drawn out unbeatly bubble by Oscar was not scripted that way. No. We were all just supposed to say unbelievable in unison. But on one of the takes, Oscar just improvised drawing out that line. It was so funny. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. It was so awesome. it there's those moments when someone makes a choice that is so funny.
我确实觉得我经历过这些对话。好吧，萨曼莎，我还想告诉你并回答你的问题，奥斯卡那个冗长、不着边际的“难以置信”并不是那样写剧本的。不。我们本来都应该齐声说“难以置信”。但在其中一个镜头里，奥斯卡只是即兴地把那句台词拉长了。太搞笑了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太
You're just, you're delighted. Like you can't believe it. Well, Brian and Warren and Halstead all loved it and they told Oscar to keep doing it, but you and I could not recover. We couldn't. We could not get through it. I am so impressed we even got one version of this
你简直，你太高兴了。就像你简直不敢相信一样。好吧，布赖恩、沃伦和霍尔斯特德都非常喜欢，他们告诉奥斯卡继续这样做，但你和我缓不过神来。我们做不到。我们根本无法撑过去。我太佩服我们甚至能录出这其中的一个版本
that they could hear. Me too. And it's in the bloopers. I think we should hear it. I wanna hear it. I want to hear it. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. Lee-va-ball.
他们能听见。我也是。而且它还在花絮里。我觉得我们应该听听。我想听。我想听。我相信这个球。我相信这个球。李瓦波。
Take care of it. Do that again. Do it again. Do that again. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. Lee-va-ball. I believe the ball.
照顾好它。再做一次。再做一次。再做一次。我相信这个球。我相信这个球。李瓦波。我相信这个球。
I believe the ball. I believe the ball. Lee-va-ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball.
我相信这个球。我相信这个球。李瓦波。我相信这个球。I believe the ball. 我相信这个球。我相信这个球。我相信这个球。
I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the ball. I believe the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil.
我相信这个球。我信这个球。我相信这个球。我相信这个球。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。
I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. I'm only the evil. Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it?
我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我只信邪。我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？
Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? Did we get it? I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Oh my God, I think I said I'm sorry like eight times. We couldn't do it. We couldn't do it. He was so funny and poor Oscar, you know, he never breaks. And he is sitting in between the two of us.
我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？对不起，对不起，对不起。天哪，我觉得我说了大概八次对不起。我们做不到。我们做不到。他太搞笑了，可怜的奥斯卡，你知道的，他从不笑场。而且他正坐在我们俩中间。
And we're those poor minds. Well, listen, before we move on from this cold open, that is just changing my whole mood. We did have a really fun fan catch in this scene. It's from Stephanie B. in Ellen Texas who wrote in to say, this is a question for Angela. At one minute and nine seconds when you're sitting at the table in the kitchen. There are like four to five unwrapped string cheese sticks in front of you. Surely, Angela would not be eating five to six cheese sticks in one sitting.
而我们这些可怜的脑子。好吧，听着，在我们从这个开场白进入下一段之前，这彻底改变了我的心情。我们在这一幕里确实捕捉到一个非常有趣的粉丝爆料。来自德克萨斯州艾伦市的斯蒂芬妮·B（Stephanie B.）来信说，这是给安吉拉的一个问题。在1分09秒时，当你坐在厨房的桌子旁。你面前大约有四到五根拆开包装的奶酪棒。安吉拉肯定不会在一坐下来就吃掉五到六根奶酪棒的。
What's up with the cheese sticks? And it's true. Here's what you have in front of you. There is a Tupperware of grapes, a Tupperware of Ritz crackers, and then a Tupperware of about a half dozen unwrapped cheese sticks. Yeah, this was me asking Phil Shea,
奶酪棒是怎么回事？这是真的。这是你面前摆着的东西：一塑料盒葡萄，一塑料盒丽树饼干，还有一个塑料盒里大约有半打拆开包装的奶酪棒。是的，这是我问菲尔·谢伊的，
can I have a little shark-cudery? How about some cheese sticks and crackers? You know, they're my go-to snack. We learned that in jury duty. You brought them to jury duty with you. I'm the one who took cheese and crackers. That's right, I bring them almost everywhere, almost every time we record,
我能来点小拼盘吗？来点奶酪棒和饼干怎么样？你知道的，这是我的首选零食。我们在陪审团义务时学到了这一点。你把它们带去陪审团义务了。我是那个带奶酪和饼干的人。没错，我几乎到处都带着它们，几乎每次我们录制时，
I have a cheese stick in my bag. This is true. I think Phil just wanted to make sure I had enough take after take. Oh my gosh. You know, I realize I've never asked you this. What is your favorite cheese? Is it a cheese stick?
我的包里都有奶酪棒。这是真的。我想菲尔只是想确保我有足够的零食，一个镜头接一个镜头地吃。哦天哪。你知道，我意识到我从来没问过你这个。你最喜欢的奶酪是什么？是奶酪棒吗？
Of all cheeses? I mean, I don't know. Lady, there's so many cheeses that I don't travel in a stick form. This is too big of a conversation. I love so many cheeses that don't travel in a stick form. This is too big of a conversation. I love so many cheeses. I like Fontina and I like Breene.
在所有的奶酪里？我是说，我不知道。天哪，有太多奶酪不是条状的。这话题太大了。我喜欢很多不是条状的奶酪。这话题太大了。我喜欢很多奶酪。我喜欢芳缇娜奶酪，我还喜欢布里奶酪。
I like Gouda. I like stinky cheeses, but your cheese stick is like a mozzarella. Sometimes I like a sharp cheddar. See what I mean? I could talk about this for a bit. Do you want to go to that place I sent it to you on Instagram? Yes. It's a conveyor belt of cheese. You know where it is? but do you want to go to that place I sent it to you on Instagram? Yes! It's a conveyor belt of cheese.
我喜欢高达奶酪。我喜欢气味重的奶酪，但你的奶酪棒就像马苏里拉奶酪。有时候我喜欢浓郁的切达奶酪。明白我的意思吗？我可以聊这个聊一会儿。你想去我在Instagram上发给你的那个地方吗？好啊！那是一个奶酪传送带。你知道它在哪儿吗？但你想去我在Instagram上发给你的那个地方吗？好啊！那是一个奶酪传送带。
You know where it is? It's in Covent Garden in London. Yeah, it's like a table and there's platters that like circle around you with cheese. Yeah, like they have sushi places like that. But this is with cheese. This is just cheese. Oh, I so want to go.
你知道它在哪儿吗？它在伦敦的考文特花园。是的，就像一张桌子，有盘子像这样绕着你转，上面摆着奶酪。对，就像他们有那种寿司店一样。但这上面是奶酪。这全都是奶酪。哦，我太想去了。
Okay. I need it to happen in our life as best friends. Okay, well we've been saying we actually want to take office ladies to London. To London! To London! So we'll eat cheese while we're there. All right, should we get into this episode?
好吧。我需要它作为好朋友在我们的生活中发生。好吧，嗯，我们一直在说我们其实想把办公室女士们带到伦敦。去伦敦！去伦敦！所以我们在那里的时候要吃奶酪。好啦，我们要进入这一集吗？
We should because it's the end of the very first week in Tallahassee. Nelly seems super pleased. They've made it through 40 hours. How do they do it? She doesn't know how they filled it. But they did it. And you know what? She thinks they need to have like a nice time tonight. Apparently, after a 40-hour work week, you have to continue hanging out with those people on a social level. Yeah. Which is my nightmare. So she invites them all to the lobby bar, I guess. But she's still not ready to name a VP, even though Dwight is trying to hypnotize her
我们应该，因为这是在塔拉哈西第一周的结束。内莉看起来超级高兴。他们熬过了40个小时。他们是怎么做到的？她不知道他们是怎么填满时间的。但他们做到了。你知道吗？她认为他们今晚需要过得愉快点。显然，在经历了40小时的工作周后，你还得在社交层面继续和那些人混在一起。对。这简直是我的噩梦。所以她邀请他们所有人去大堂酒吧，我猜。但她仍然没有准备好任命副总裁，尽管德怀特正试图催眠她
into thinking he should be the one. Yeah, well listen, she tried hypnosis. It didn't work. She smoked more. Oh no. Kathy is going to approach Jim. And she just sort of says, hey, maybe we'll see the real Telenasty we've been hearing about. Yeah. Yeah. But Gabe is annoyed. He doesn't want Kathy taking credit for creating Telenasty. She didn't. Okay. Well
让他觉得他应该是那个人。好吧，听着，她尝试了催眠。没用。她抽了更多烟。哦，不。凯茜要去找吉姆。她只是随口说，嘿，也许我们会看到我们一直听说真正的塔拉哈西。是啊。是啊。但盖布很恼火。他不想让凯茜抢走创造“塔拉哈西”的功劳。她才没有。好吧，
you know what? Gabe is right. Kathy didn't make up Telenasty. I looked it up. According to the internet, I guess it's meant to be an insult made by the University of Florida students to slight their rival Florida State University's city. And let me just tell y'all If you put a hashtag in front of talent asked me on Instagram. Oh, no, what do you see a lot of people having a good time? Oh, they're just living it up. Okay, they're partying a lot. I'm gonna tell you, based on everything we've learned about telehassy
你知道吗？盖布是对的。凯茜并没有编造塔拉哈西。我查过了。根据互联网上的说法，这似乎是佛罗里达大学的学生用来贬低他们的竞争对手——佛罗里达州立大学所在城市的一个侮辱词。让我告诉你们大家，如果你在Instagram上的“塔拉哈西”前面加一个井号。哦，不，你会看到什么？很多人玩得很开心？哦，他们玩得很疯狂。好吧，根据我们在塔拉哈西了解到的所有情况，
since we've been on this story arc, I think it sounds like a lovely charming town that I cannot wait to go to. Well, there's some folks that really like to party. Well, listen, maybe that'll make it great too. It's got no shade, got some nightlife. Hashtag tellin' nasty. Stanley and Jim are gonna be in a car now, and they're gonna pull up alongside a couple
自从我们开始这个故事情节以来，我觉得它听起来像是一个可爱迷人的小镇，我已经迫不及待想去了。好吧，有些人真的很喜欢派对。好吧，听着，也许那也会让它变得很棒。这里没有阴凉处，有些夜生活。井号：塔拉哈西。斯坦利和吉姆现在要上车了，他们将把车停在一对夫妇旁边
of women, and Stanley is going to invite them for drinks, and maybe to go dancing. And Jim is kinda trying to be invisible. We got a fan question from Abigail H. and Brisbane Australia who asked, this is a general question about casting extras. I thought of it when I watched the scene where Stanley and Jim are driving. And they asked the ladies in the car next to them to get a cocktail. What is the process for casting extras like this? Do people have to audition for these roles? Are they just random family or friends of the cast?
女性们，然后斯坦利邀请她们去喝一杯，可能还会去跳舞。吉姆则有点想当隐形人。我们收到了来自澳大利亚布里斯班的阿比盖尔·H的粉丝提问，这是一个关于群演选角的通用问题。当我看到斯坦利和吉姆开车的那个场景时，我想到了这个问题。他们邀请车里隔壁的女士们去喝一杯鸡尾酒。这种群演的选角过程是怎样的？人们需要为这些角色试镜吗？他们只是剧组的随机家人或朋友吗？
Well Abigail, that's a really good question. So no, those background actors are sag actors. They are part of the union. And what happens is you'll put a call out, the casting director, we'll put a call out, and they'll specify kind of what they need, the background, for a performer to do. So in this case, they probably put out a call for like two attractive women, of a certain age, and then a bunch of photos will get sent into the production and then they'll sort of pick people based on their photograph. Yes, because these are non-speaking roles. They're background actors,
嗯，阿比盖尔，这是一个非常好的问题。所以，不，那些背景演员是美国演员工会演员。他们是工会的一部分。情况是这样的，你会发出通告，选角导演会发出通告，他们会明确说明他们对背景表演者的需求。所以在这种情况下，他们可能发出了这样的通告：需要两个一定年龄的有魅力的女性，然后一堆照片会被发送到剧组，接着他们会根据照片来挑选人。是的，因为这些是没有台词的角色。他们是背景演员，
so they didn't need to come in an audition, but they would have had their photos looked at to see if they were the right fit. Yes, and so similarly, like a couple weeks ago, when they were making the pyramid in the conference room, they put out a call for background actors who were willing to get into a human pyramid. Yeah. You know, and there are agencies that you sign up for if you want to be a background performer. And we both did that. Yes, I did it for many years. I looked a lot about what it was like to be on a set.
所以他们不需要来试镜，但他们的照片会被审阅，看看是否合适。是的，类似地，就在几周前，当他们在会议室里制作金字塔时，他们发布了一个招募背景演员的通告，这些人愿意组成一个人类金字塔。是的。你知道的，如果你想成为一名背景演员，有一些你可以报名的机构。我们俩都做过。是的，我做了很多年。我对片场的生活有了很多了解。
Yeah. It's such great experience. It's a great education. We're now going to shift over to Dunderclind. Andy addresses the bull pin. He said it's time to put their pencils down. The workday is done, but hey, also lift them back up because it's the late night work jam. Andy and Pam are really trying to get everyone fired up. They're, you know, doing this chant, I'm good to go! In the background, Angela goes, stop it, stop it. That was improvised.
是的。这真是太棒的经历了。这是一次极好的教育。我们现在要转向邓德米林。安迪对员工们发表了讲话。他说现在是放下铅笔的时候了。工作日结束了，但是，嘿，也把它们重新举起来，因为这是深夜工作狂欢。安迪和帕姆真的在努力让每个人都兴奋起来。他们，你知道的，在做这个口号，我准备好了！在背景中，安吉拉说，停下，停下。那是即兴发挥的。
Oh, I love that! I wanna say something. I really love Kelly's sweater in this episode. Yeah. It is this sort of gold yellow color that I'm currently obsessed with. It all started when we did our Chili's commercial Angela and the stylist pulled this gorgeous gold silk blouse
哦，我太喜欢那个了！我想说点什么。我真的很喜欢凯利在这集里毛衣。是的。这是那种我目前着迷的金黄色。这一切都始于我们拍摄奇利斯广告的时候，安吉拉，造型师拿出了一件华丽的金色丝绸衬衫
for me. Yes, you texted me. Cause we couldn't do our fittings on the same day. You went first and I was like, so what they put you in and you said, I think I'm aware this gold yellow blouse and I was like, are you sure? I don't know. It sounded a little like, what?
给我。是的，你发短信给我。因为我们不能在同一天试穿。你先去的，然后我说，那么他们给你穿什么呢，你说，我想我穿的是这件金黄色衬衫，我说，你确定吗？我不知道。听起来有点像，什么？
It's not a color you normally wear. No, you know, she brought over this rack of clothes and she was pulling things out. And she was like, this is kind of my favorite. And it was this gold blouse. And I said, I don't wear a yellow. I don't think it's gonna look good on me. Yeah.
这不是你通常穿的颜色。不，你知道，她拿来了一排衣服，把东西拿出来。她说，这有点是我的最爱。这就是那件金色衬衫。我说，我不穿黄色。我觉得它不会适合我。是的。
And as any good stylist would, she said, give it a try. I loved it. I felt it. I just so in love with it, that I begged the Chili's people to keep it. And they said, yes, so I still have it. And then later, you know, I ended up buying a gold sundress. I become obsessed with this color yellow
就像任何优秀的造型师一样，她说，试试看。我很喜欢。我能感觉到。我太喜欢它了，以至于我恳求奇利斯的人把它留给我。他们说，好的，所以我现在还留着它。然后后来，你知道的，我最终买了一条金色太阳裙。我开始迷恋这种黄色的颜色
and Kelly is wearing it. I don't know. I'm obsessed. I want to like decorate a room in this color. But speaking of wardrobe from this episode, we got a fan question from Lex and Pennsylvania, who would like to point out something about Jim's casual wear. Okay.
而凯利正穿着它。我不知道。我着迷了。我想用这种颜色来装饰一个房间。但说到这一集的戏服，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州莱克斯的粉丝提问，他想指出关于吉姆休闲装的一点。好的。
Lex said throughout the series, Jim wears the same gray sweater in jeans anytime he's out of the office. Really? Lex did a mini deep dive and noticed that the gray sweater in jeans combo shows up in casual Friday and he's play viewing party, pool party, after hours, and finale. Lex said, what's the deal with the gray sweater? I think that's kind of cute.
莱克斯说，在整个系列中，吉姆在办公室外面时总是穿同一件灰色毛衣和牛仔裤。真的吗？莱克斯做了一次微型深入研究，发现灰色毛衣加牛仔裤的组合出现在休闲星期五、观影派对、泳池派对、下班后和结局中。莱克斯说，这件灰色毛衣是怎么回事？我觉得这挺可爱的。
I kind of feel like he has his favorite kind of hang out sweater. Yeah. I kind of love it too. And you're right, Lex. Like once you pointed it out, I realized, yeah, he does every time. Where's the same sweater? So Andy's going to explain that they're staying late tonight to service the accounts of the employees who are in Florida. Mm-hmm. Pam does point out they could have been doing that all along, but whatever, they're now gonna stay late. I loved how Pam popped into Andy's talking head. Yeah, that was cute.
我有点觉得他有他最喜欢的闲逛毛衣。是的。我也挺喜欢的。你是对的，莱克斯。一旦你指出来，我意识到，是的，他每次都这样。穿着同一件毛衣？所以安迪将要解释他们今晚要留下来处理那些在佛罗里达的员工的账户。嗯。帕姆确实指出他们本可以一直那样做的，但不管怎样，他们现在要留下来了。我喜欢帕姆突然插话进入安迪的单人访谈。是的，那很可爱。
I remember when we shot that, I was so excited because you always see Dwight doing that to Michael. Yeah. And it was so delighted to get to do it. I know, I know. It's a classic office moment where you're in the boss's office. You think the boss is alone and then someone pops in. We all coveted this bit.
我记得我们拍那一幕的时候，我非常兴奋，因为你总是看到德怀特对迈克尔那样。是的。能够这样做我感到非常高兴。我知道，我知道。这是一个经典的办公室时刻，你在老板的办公室里。你以为老板一个人在，然后有人突然进来。我们都渴望这个桥段。
I got to do it one time with Michael when I'm himming his pants. I remember. I love it. Well Hallstead said this idea of the office staying late at work. That storyline needed to happen because they needed to have a nighttime storyline for the people at the office to mirror what was happening in Tallahassee for purposes of the documentary. Yes, exactly. But Halsted said it was very easy for them to come up with funny bits for this office storyline because the writers often stayed at work until about 10 o'clock,
我有一次和迈克尔一起做过，当时我在给他改裤边。我记得。我喜欢。霍尔斯特德说办公室加班工作的这个想法。这个故事情节是必须发生的，因为为了纪录片的目的，他们需要一个夜间故事情节让办公室的人来呼应塔拉哈西发生的事情。是的，完全正确。但是霍尔斯特德说，他们想出这个办公室故事情节的搞笑段子非常容易，因为编剧们经常工作到晚上10点左右，
storyline because the writers often stayed at work until about 10 o'clock, working on scripts, and they would get punchy or people would shout things out or like food would come. Anyway, they drew on their personal experience for this storyline. Well, you know, I was really curious about the idea of working after closing time and where the term after hours came from. So here's what I found. It's an expression that became popular in the 1800s. 1800s. Yes! The phrase after hours? Yes! It originated when governments passed certain laws to regulate business hours. And once businesses were meant to close, it became after hours. So it also gave rise to the term after hours club for a drinking club that remained open
一直在写剧本，他们会变得思维敏捷，或者人们会大喊大叫，或者食物会送来。无论如何，他们从个人经历中汲取了灵感来创作这个故事情节。嗯，你知道，我对下班后工作的想法以及“下班后”（after hours）这个词的来源非常好奇。所以这就是我找到的。这是一个在1800年代流行起来的表达。1800年代！是的！“下班后”这个短语？是的！它起源于政府通过某些法律来规范营业时间的时候。一旦企业应该关门了，这就变成了下班后。所以这也催生了“下班后俱乐部”（after hours club）这个词，用来指那些营业时间比合法场所更晚的饮酒俱乐部。
later than legal establishments. Oh. Yeah. So the term after hours has been around for a long time. Wow. I don't know. Well, speaking of after hours drinking, everyone in telehazze is at the bar. Packer and Nelly disagree on who would win in a fight
哦。是的。所以“after hours”这个词已经存在很长时间了。哇。我不知道。说到下班后喝酒，塔拉哈西的所有人都在酒吧里。帕克和耐莉对谁能在杰森·伯恩和詹姆斯·邦德的打斗中获胜意见不一
between Jason Bourne and James Bond. Who do you think would win in a fight between Jason Bourne and James Bond? Because I checked all the message boards and there is a very clear opinion on the matter. 100% Jason Bourne. You're correct. Yeah. I mean, he knows how many paces
你认为在杰森·伯恩和詹姆斯·邦德的打斗中谁会赢？因为我查阅了所有的留言板，对于这件事有一个非常明确的看法。100%是杰森·伯恩。你是对的。是的。我的意思是，他知道从他坐的地方到门有多少步
from the, where he's sitting to the door. He just has a lot more experience with hand-to-hand combat. Mm-hmm. Is what everyone said. I got curious who would want a fight between Jason Bourne and John Wick. Oh gosh.
距离。他在近身搏击方面有更多的经验。嗯。这就是每个人都说的。我很好奇在杰森·伯恩和约翰·威克之间的打斗中谁会赢。哦天哪。
Why you got to do that to me? Why do I have to pick? Well, the fan forums say Jason Bourne again. Apparently Jason Bourne is just the s**tness. Yeah. Have you seen John Wick, like drive a car with one arm and shoot out the other side doing a 360? Come on.
为什么你要对我做这个？为什么我非得选？好吧，粉丝论坛再次选择了杰森·伯恩。显然杰森·伯恩就是那么厉害。是的。你见过约翰·威克单手开车，另一边开枪，还做360度旋转吗？拜托。
If you give John Wick a car, and a ton of like none chucks And ammo or a giant sword He's how I don't know I'm going John Wick. Well, I mean fan forums just really Think that Jason born I guess is the best listen if you let Jason born get up close to you You're done so you're done, so. But maybe John Wick could get him from a distance. Well, Dwight's money is on Genghis Khan because he was willing to kill children.
如果你给约翰·威克一辆车，和一大堆双截棍还有弹药或者一把巨剑。他是——我不知道，我选约翰·威克。好吧，我的意思是粉丝论坛真的认为杰森·伯恩我猜是最好的。听着，如果你让杰森·伯恩靠近你，你就完了。所以你就完了。但也许约翰·威克可以从远距离干掉他。好吧，德怀特的赌注押在成吉思汗身上，因为他愿意杀害儿童。
Oh my gosh, Dwight always makes it weird. He always makes it awkward for him. There's so many more moments like this that were in the shooting draft and in deleted scenes. Where Dwight takes it one step too weird. So bizarre. He said, there's a moment, Jenna, where Dwight is trying to flirt with Nelly and he's trying to one up, Packer.
哦天哪，德怀特总是把它弄得很诡异。他总是让自己感到尴尬。拍摄剧本和被删减的片段中还有很多这样时刻。德怀特把事情做得太诡异了。太离奇了。他说，有一个时刻，珍娜，德怀特正试图调情耐莉，他试图胜过帕克。
Nelly says to Packer, ooh, in new Indo. And Dwight jumps in and goes, in your Indo. No! And Nelly goes, watch it, watch it it. Like all right. Just pump the brakes. There were so many more moments like this is all I'm saying. Ah. Well meanwhile Ryan and Aaron are sitting together and Ryan orders a shard nay and Aaron orders a waterfall. No, no, no. What? He orders the oakyest shardinay they have. What is with the writers and oaky? They love oaky afterbure. I know. Oaky. You know what? They don't have any waffles. Yeah, and Aaron knows what she wants, and it's a hotel waffle.
耐莉对帕克说，哦，印第安纳州（new Indo）。而德怀特跳出来说，在你的印第安纳州（in your Indo）。不！耐莉说，注意点，注意点。就像好吧。踩刹车吧。我的意思是，还有很多这样的时刻。啊。与此同时，瑞安和艾琳坐在一起，瑞安点了一杯霞多丽（shard nay），而艾琳点了一杯瀑布（waterfall）。不，不，不。什么？他点的是他们有的橡木味最浓的霞多丽。编剧们和橡木味有什么仇？他们太喜欢橡木味余味了。我知道。橡木味。你知道吗？他们根本没有华夫饼。是的，艾琳知道她想要什么，那就是酒店华夫饼。
Well, this is when Aaron decides to tell Ryan about her plan to stay in Florida. And I guess Ryan sees this as the perfect opportunity to hook up with her and then not have to deal with her. Yeah, exactly. So now that's his mission. I'm gonna hook up with Aaron. I'm gonna get her a waffle. That's my way in. Back in the conference room at Dunder Mifflin,
好吧，这就是艾琳决定告诉瑞安她留在佛罗里达的计划的时候。我猜瑞安认为这是和她鬼混然后又不用应付她的绝佳机会。是的，完全正确。所以现在这就是他的任务。我要和艾琳鬼混。我要给她弄个华夫饼。这就是我的切入点。回到邓德米林的会议室,
the late night work jam is underway, but Kelly, Kelly cannot take it. She can't take it. This is how the scene starts. Pam says Watson carpet and tile. Kevin says one order. Oscar says order reference number zero zero nine eight three dash one two six. Phyllis says eight cases bright white inkjet. Angela says paid Kelly yells, I'm dying! Gerald says processed, vals says, and delivered. So, Halston and Warren reminded me about the
深夜工作狂欢正在进行中，但是凯利，凯利受不了了。她受不了了。这就是场景开始的方式。帕姆说沃森地毯和瓷砖。凯文说一份订单。奥斯卡说订单参考号零零九八三杠一二六。菲利斯说八箱亮白喷墨纸。安吉拉说已付款。凯利大喊，我要死了！杰拉尔德说已处理，瓦尔说，已交付。所以，霍尔斯特德和沃恩提醒了我
very real-life inspiration for Kelly's line, and as soon as they reminded me, I started laughing. Oh my god, lady, I remembered it instantly. It was like a wave of memories had washed over me. You have to share this story. So you guys know that I love to host a Yankee swap party. I was inspired by our show. I started hosting one. Well, one year, one year, a friend of ours brought a new date. We're all like, oh, who's the new gal?
关于凯利那句台词的真实生活灵感，他们一提醒我，我就开始大笑。天哪，亲爱的，我立刻就想起来了。就像一股记忆的浪潮向我涌来。你必须分享这个故事。所以你们知道我喜欢举办白色大象交换派对。我受到了我们节目的启发。我开始举办一个。嗯，有一年，有一年，我们的一个朋友带了一个新约会对象。我们都在想，哦，那个新姑娘是谁？
We were playing Yankee swap and I guess she didn't care for it. And just out of the blue, she literally said, I'm dying. Like she hated the game. She was so miserable. I think she was really bored by us. She also said at one time, well, I'm pretty sure none of you have traveled as much as I have. She was like pissing people off, left and right. But Halstead said when she said I'm dying to him, it felt like more like a verbal slip like from her real true life in her monologue. Yes. And he and Warren thought it was hilarious. They remembered it and they wrote it into this episode. This is my favorite thing about writers is how they
我们正在玩白色大象交换游戏，我猜她并不在乎。突然间，她真的说，我要死了。就像她讨厌这个游戏一样。她太痛苦了。我想她真的对我们感到厌烦。她还曾说过，嗯，我很确信你们没有一个人像我一样旅行过这么多。她惹恼了所有人，左右开弓。但霍尔斯特德说，当她对他说“我要死了”时，感觉更像是一个口误，就像来自她真实生活中的独白。是的。他和沃恩认为这太搞笑了。他们记住了并把它写进了这一集。这就是我最喜欢编剧的地方，他们
just file away. Yeah. A little moment. They observe and they file away. They're like, that'll come out of the file at just the right moments. They observe and they file away. They're like, that'll come out of the file at just the right time. And this was it with Kelly. Oh my gosh. Warren and I were talking yesterday. We were cracking up about this moment. Uh, this whole Nelly Packer Dwight Flirty Triangle is now going on strong.
Oh gosh, it's so uncomfortable. Packers like, hey, the cowgirl has chosen her saddle. Like that. Yeah. That was, that, it was not in the script. It wasn't. That was just Dave Kekner. That's a Kekner special.
But then Rainmashed it as Dwight. It's just so, like funny, because he did it as only Dwight would do it, like kind of cringey. I mean, they're both cringey. Dwight says, you know what, if anyone's going to sleep with Nelly for a personal gain, it's going to be him. Well, there was a candy bag alt for this Dwight talking head. Please tell me. It was a must shoot. Okay. So you know it lives out there somewhere. Dwight would have said, if I can get ahead by shaking a certain hand, padding a back, or you know, and then he motions to his penis,
I'll do it. This is a team effort. No part of Dwight's trute sits on the bench. Wow. OK. All hands on deck, if you will. Ah. Well, meanwhile, back in the conference room, Andy has brought in dinner, a nice gesture.
Yeah. And he wants everyone to know it's not pizza or tacos. He went another way with it. It's a Jamaican feast brought to them by Val's boyfriend Brandon. Yeah, her boy, her boy. Yeah. Bringing in the food. Phyllis is snarky.
She says, if I want to Jamaican food, I'd just hire a bodyguard and go there. Oscar tries to bond with Brandon. He says, oh man, I was just reading about these elections in Jamaica and Brandon's like, yeah, yeah, no, I'm not from Jamaica. Yeah, I noticed Angela right after Phyllis says that line, you itch your nose, real big.
Like super big nose itch. Okay. I don't know. Sometimes those are the things you see. Maybe someone was thinking of me. Oh yeah, it doesn't your nose get itchy if someone's thinking of you? That's what my mom always says.
Yes, I remember that. Aw, someone was thinking of you in that moment. You always have it. Or I just had a runny nose or something. I don't know. I don't know. Darryl is going to introduce himself to Brandon. And then Brandon immediately accuses him of sleeping with Val. Oh, F-bombs were dropped.
I love everything about Jerry Minor in this episode, but one of my favorite lines of his is in the scene. It's when Brandon says, I hope you all like goat. Yeah. I wasn't even sure if that was scripted. I went to the script. It is scripted. Warren was like, it was scripted, but I
have to give all credit to Jerry Miner, the way he delivered it steals the show. I thought the not baby girl was improvised. When Angela says, is it spicy? He just throws that away. So perfectly. Yeah, baby girl. It was scripted. Scripted girl was improvised when Angela says is it spicy? He just throws that away. So Perfectly. No baby girl. It was scripted scripted not improvised. No, he just made it feel so spontaneous. I watched that scene like three times because it charm me so much. Huls did share with us that this Jamaican feast idea was inspired because when they would stay late at night as writers, how
you mentioned, they would order from restaurants and they would often just pick new random places so they weren't getting the same food over and over. Yes. And I guess the production assistance would order and so the writers weren't sure where things were coming from. And he said there was always someone who would complain. And they were always surprised. And as a result, they ended up eating a lot of strange things. I love it.
Well, listen, maybe we should take a break because Jim is getting ready to turn in for the night, and all hell is gonna break loose in that hotel room, and I have so much to say. Yeah, someone's heater is broken. Yeah. But she's wearing Ugg boots anyway. Don't get me started. She's hot, but she's wearing Uggs.
What? In Florida. Florida. Let's pump the brakes there, Catherine. We'll be back. We are back. While Dwight and Pack are laying it on thick with Nelly, Jim has decided to turn in for the night. And you see this kind of spy shot from outside of his hotel room.
You see Stanley walking past the sort of what would you call that patio door? Yeah, like a gym room with a woman that he has met. I was gonna say is this one of our fancy shots? Yes, lady. For reasons I'll explain later, I was at this location and I remember this shot and I remember that it was super elaborate, but I couldn't remember why. I remember it took a very long time to set up, and I was like, what was that? And Hallstead reminded me that in order to get this establishing spy shot of Jim's hotel room, it was complicated because that room was on the second floor of the hotel.
It looks like it's on the ground floor, and he has like doors that open up to a patio, but no, this was on the second floor. So they had to cheat it. They cheated it. They rented a crane that they had to bring in and put the camera on and Stanley and his date are actually walking on the roof outside.
Like it's not really like a place to walk. It was a total cheat. Wow. I know. Well, I thought it looked really cool. I like seeing Jim's room from that angle that really sold that motel kind of look. Well, they wanted it to be a spy shot.
This first moment of Kathy kind of coming to Jim's door, you know, but we had to make up a reason why we could have cameras outside the room. It had to be like that Jim's room was on the first floor, right? And we were spying in, because they wouldn't have rented a drone or a crane. But we did.
We rented a crane. So here is where it all begins. Kathy and her uggs says that the heater is on the fritz in her room, and it's like super hot. And can she just hang in Jim's room until maintenance is done fixing it? And Jim is kind of like, oh, I, yeah, I guess so. Also, she didn't show up in her clothes that she had on at the bar. Right.
She's now in a tank top and what looks like to be kind of like pajama box or shorts. Yes. So now she's in his room and they're gonna watch March Madness, but it's not March. They're gonna watch Basketball. It's not March? No, that was the joke.
She's like, oh, you're watching Basketball? And he's like, yeah, yeah. Come on in. And she's like, oh, you're watching basketball and he's like, yeah, yeah, come on in and she's like, oh, I love March, Mattis and under his breath He's like March, Mattis isn't March That's so funny and then catch that and since Kathy takes over the bed Jim kind of awkwardly sits on the floor Also, I'm sorry Who just goes and sits on a married man's bed? Kathy, a panherpajamas.
Yeah, that's what she's gonna sit. Let me say so far. So far, I see how Jim was kind of like, dearly haggly. Bamboo, like, a little bit like, blah, blah, blah, wait. Oh, oh, maintenance is in your room. And now you just need some place to be. And like, you know, Kathy was thinking ahead. She's like, if I come dressed, Jim might say,
well, let's go down to the bar. Well, wait, but you know, you can't really take her down to the bar in this pajama outfit. Mm-hmm. So he's kind of stuck with her. Yes. At this point, at this point, it makes sense. Yes.
We're giving him a pass. Meanwhile, back in the conference room, Kelly is finally invested. Kelly is like this night went from being the worst to being the best. She's not going anywhere. No. And it's going to get real juicy because Brandon is going to tell everyone that Darryl texted Val late at night. Midnight.
Mm-hmm. I'm sorry. Midnight, texting. Nothing good happens after midnight. That's what my mom would say. Yeah. What I'd want to stay out late. Kelly insists that they hear the texts. Well, here they are. And I do think a few of them crossed the line.
Yeah. Darryl starts to read them. The first one is, I got too much ice cream, you want some. Getting my fry on. The moon is huge tonight. Okay, that one. That was what stopped everyone in the conference room. I agree with Phyllis.
And Brandon says, you forgot one. Darryl reads, you're such a great friend, and then Brandon says, with the dots. So Darryl rereads the text, you're such a great friend, dot dot dot dot dot. Kelly explodes. Explodes, five dots, Darryl, are you kidding me? She says three dots means to be continued.
Four dots is a typo, but five dots means, whoa, do not make me say what I want to say baby, but if I did, it would blow your mind. Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. When we were trading messages with Warren and Halstead, I told them how much I loved dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. And Warren reminded me that in season seven, he and Halstead wrote that episode China where Darryl and Andy have that storyline about texting about what is worthy of a text. And you know, they said texting etiquette at this time.
We were talking about it a lot. It was still new, guys. We're old. This is old text stuff. It kind of is. But they really like the idea that texting late at night is something that would get Darryl into trouble. Yeah.
The scene would have continued. It was longer. And in the end, Brandon goes storming out with vowel chasing after him. Here's what it said in the shooting draft. OK. vowel chases after him leaving Darrell upset, everyone's silent. Andy produces a pump and some balloons from his pocket. Andy says
to Meredith, Meredith, if you could have any balloon animal in the world that was either a dog or a snake, which would it be? So wait, lady, I am like memories are flooding back to me of shooting this Yes, Ed like pumping the balloon to make these balloons and they were all horrible They were terrible so you guys if you've noticed a bunch of weird looking balloon animals On the conference room table they were Ed Helms' attempts I On the conference room table, they were Ed Helms' attempts. I am so remembering this now, we laughed so hard because I think, you know, the people who do balloon animals,
to Meredith, Meredith, if you could have any balloon animal in the world that was either a dog or a snake, which would it be? So wait, lady, I am like memories are flooding back to me of shooting this Yes, ed like pumping the balloon to make these balloons and they were all horrible They were terrible so you guys if you've noticed a bunch of weird looking balloon animals On the conference room table they were Ed Helms' attempts I On the conference room table, they were Ed Helms' attempts. I am so remembering this now, we laughed so hard because I think, you know, the people who do balloon animals,
they make it look so easy. I know. And I think we just all took for granted, like the writers, Brian is director, Ed, all of us that just like, he could just make something and we knew like, oh, they were not going to come out great. Yeah.
But like, he was like, he couldn't even get them to like twist, make an X like he could do if they just kept flying everywhere. And also, also, it was way more pumping than I think. It's got so much pumping time. It was so much time spent pumping the balloons. Oh my gosh. Yeah. A fun pumping the balloons. Oh my gosh. Yeah. A fun thing to remember.
Oh my gosh. I was cracking up and you know, part of it's in deleted scenes, but then you see the balloons on the conference table and later scenes. They're so awful. They're awful. And this was Andy's way of like easing the tension.
Oh my goodness. Oh, thank you for reminding me of that. Well, things might have taken a turn for Tallinasty back in Tallahassee because now Packer is doing the cherry stem thing. Where he's tying it with his tongue into a knot. And this made me laugh so hard. When Dwight says, please, anyone can tie a knot. The real Talents and untie it.
And he takes the cherry stem that was in Packer's mouth and puts it in his mouth. And then he works real hard to untie it. You guys, indelated scenes, this moment plays out. And rain is white is really struggling. He's working so hard on that Terry stem and there is just this awkward silence as Nelly and Packer watched white. And then ultimately he un-nots it
and he spits it out and then he holds it up and he goes, there it is, straight enough to pick your teeth with. He's like handing it to Nelly. It's so disgusting. Oh my gosh. This is our second cherry stem reference on the office. Remember Ben Franklin? Oh yeah. Was. Was Ty and Cherry stem? Was an expert with the cherry stem.
Well, also in telehassy, Aaron and Ryan have sneaked into the hotel kitchen to make a waffle. And I'll have you know that we shot these kitchen scenes in the actual hotel kitchens. It looked real. Yes. In the morning, we took over the hotel bar and in the afternoon, we took over the kitchen. And you know, I'm always fascinated by the inner workings of the production, like, how does this work? And I asked Steve Burgess and he said, you know, we shot at this hotel
over two different weeks for two different episodes. He said, it was like a whole ordeal. Like, we took over their parking lot. We took over the whole second floor of the hotel. On various days, we were in the lobby, or the bar, or the kitchen. During the week, we kept all our stuff there. They had guards that would guard everything,
like 24 hours a day, but we would move it all back to our stages for the weekend. Because it wasn't just the stuff in the hotel, either in the parking lot, where all the crew trucks and all the trailers and where we would eat lunch, you know, that was like where you would have catering for lunch. It's like a whole thing.
Logistically that is so much work. Like it's like every week, you completely move into your house and then you move out. Yes, imagine that. Yes, exactly. People working around the clock to make that happen. Just amazing. So also in the scene, Aaron says, oh wow, they left the lights on. And Ryan says that they leave the lights on because it's less expensive than turning them on and off. And Aaron is really impressed with how smart he is. Yeah. You know, well, I decided to check this out. I wanted to fact check Ryan.
Is this true because you know, sometimes you drive through a city late at night and you see these big tall business buildings. And you know no one's in them really because it's nighttime and all the lights are on. Well, according to energy.gov, the cost effectiveness of when to turn the lights on or off depends on the kind of bulb and the cost of electricity.
So light bulbs have a kind of operating life, and that can be affected by how many times they're turned on and off, so the more often they're switched on and off, the lower their operating life. But I can get more specific with you. In-can-descent lighting should definitely be turned off if you're not using it, because they're the least efficient kind of lighting. They give off a lot of heat.
You'll keep your room cooler by turning them off, and you'll use less electricity. Halogen lighting is slightly more efficient, but should also be turned off when not in use. However, fluorescent lighting is the light that where you shorten the lightspan if you turn it on and off. And there's a popular belief that these lights use a lot of energy to get started, which is true. You know, when you turn on fluorescent lights, it's like, good to do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, but on the replacement cost, like you'd have to replace
those fluorescent lights more often. So I guess Ryan's right. Because then your carbon footprint is building more lights, using more materials, using the machinery to make the lights. And the cost of having to buy all the light bulbs and the labor and putting them in. Yeah. So I guess Ryan's right. I was annoyed. I wanted Ryan to be wrong. Ryan is working so hard to get late. My gosh. He's really working hard. It made me cringe. It did me too. So listen, all of a sudden though, people are going to come in this kitchen. And I guess what they decide to do, rather than just act like, oh my gosh, sorry, we didn't
mean to be in here. We got turned around, which is what I would do if I was caught sneaking into a kitchen. They decide to hide in the kitchen, a la Jurassic Park, kind of like under the table from the raptors. So that's what it reminded me of. You know what's a great thing to do if you're somewhere and you maybe shouldn't be in that part of a building? Okay, what?
If you're a discovered, what? Just say bathroom. Why do we have so many excuses? Why are we so ready to get out of a situation where we're in a part of a building? You know what I mean? Have we done in a part of a building we should be in. Have we done this a lot in our life? Why?
I think we're both like snoops and we're like, we're both like, oh, oh, it's the kitchen. Oh, no one's in. Let's go look. Let's see what's in there. It's very innocent, but I think you and I both snoop a little bit. I think you're right. And so we have it on the ready. Why are we?
Yeah. Oh, I'm so sorry, I got turned around. I'm sorry, bathroom? On the next episode of Mom Detectives. Well, we're gonna use both of those excuses. I know. I know. I know. Upcoming snoop. Let's go back to Jim's room.
There's a knock at the door. It's Stanley. Oh, Jim's so relieved. Yes, come in. Come in. Come in. Come in. Watch the game with us. Yes, Stanley just wants some rum. For some reason his Mini fridge is out of rum. I wonder why I wonder Florida Stanley and
Stanley clocks that Kathy's on the bed and he's like, oh, it gets easier and easier Jim Mm-hmm and Jim's like, no, that's not what's and he's like whatever and he leaves So Jim is gonna have to enlist Dwight. Yeah, he's come up with a plan of how to get Kathy out of his room. Cause I guess he's too nice to just ask her to leave. That's my bullsh** card. I know.
Just ask her to leave. Say, I'm tired, I need you to go. I need to go to bed. Yeah, I actually need to call Pam and catch up with a few things. Mm-hmm. I'm going to ask you to go. Have a good night.
I've got a fan mail flurry on this subject. Right. I'm getting it laid. I'm my bullshit part. I had to play one. So Jim finds Dwight, interrupts his seduction plan to tell him there are bed bugs in his room. Mm-hmm.
Because talk about playing the player. This is going to freak Dwight out. Bed bugs. He'll be right there. Yeah. But then Dwight's like, oh, I don't want Packer to hook up with Nelly. So he goes up to Gabe and says, I need you to help me sabotage this. Yeah. This is when we find out Gabe's full name. Gabriel, Susan Lewis. G-S-L. What's in it for G-S-L? What's in it for G-S-L? Dwight's like, do you really want Packer as a boss?
That's all he needed to hear. Dwight is going to burst into Jim's room, forces Kathy off the bed so that he can shake out all the covers and find the bedbugs. Then Dwight starts interrogating Jim. He's searching his hair and asking him a whole bunch of questions about his encounter with the bedbuck. Dwight says, where did you see it? Jim says in the bed. Dwight's like, we got to find it before it eggs. Describe it. Jim says brown, shiny, painful bite. Dwight, hmm, could be a batweevil,
describe its mood. Did it seem sleepy? Jim, stressed, but to be fair, it was a tense situation. Dwight, fair enough, but after it bit you, did it run away fearful or did it walk away smug? Self-assured. Jim, so smug, like you thought it was funny, like this. Dwight's like, that's a bed bug. Everything's a joke. Lady, so I told like, that's a bed bug. Everything's a joke. Lady, so I told you I was at this location and I arrived and they were getting ready to shoot this scene. It was so funny. The first time John imitated the smug bed bug, it was the same as the unbelievable scene. Like, rain was like shocked at how funny it was
and he started laughing and they could not get through it. Like every time John imitated the smug bed bug, oh my God, it was amazing. I was sitting with Brian at the directors monitor and I remember coming into work the next day on our stages and I was trying to like recreate it for everyone. I was trying to explain like you guys you don't understand it was like 30 minutes of trying to get John to imitate a smug bed bug because we're laughing so hard and nobody got it. It was like
crickets. I was like just wait till this episode comes out. I remember at the end of our season wrap party, they put the bloopers from it. Yes. There were so many, and we were dying. We were dying. It was so hilarious. I was so happy they did that because I finally felt like everyone could see and share in this moment that is like one of the hardest we ever laughed on the set. That was always one of my favorite things of the wrap party
because you know, there are a few bloopers that live out there. You can find them on YouTube and places like that. But our editors would make a huge extended bloopers cut for the wrap party. Oh my gosh, I don't know how they ever got one take of that. That was so good. There are so many moments between Jim and Dwight
in this hotel room like when Dwight says that he farted constantly on the sheet to make a greenhouse like how do they get through any of it. Oh my gosh. Well Dwight is going to now remove all of his clothing like you said he's going to get into the bed under the covers. He's going to attract the bed bugs at the body heat. Yes exactly. Also when he went through Jim's hair, yeah, come on. Well, Kathy is so disgusted. She's like, I need to take a shower. And Jim's like, yes, she's sleeping.
Yes, bye. And then she goes into his bathroom. I am sorry, second bullsh** card. Who does that? Who does that? I do have a third bullsh** card to play. How is Dwight jumping into a bed? He had his appendix out just the week before.
How is he doing any of this? Angela! This was a fan catch from Angela B in a new answer. From an amp? Wait, a person named Angela. A double Angela, you and another Angela. Same brain. Also, AJ from Edmonton, Alberta, wanted to know why when he on dress is, Angela, Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela.
How is he doing any of this? Angela! This was a fan catch from Angela B in a new answer. From an amp? Wait, a person named Angela. A double Angela, you and another Angela. Same brain. Also, AJ from Edmonton, Alberta, wanted to know why when he on dress is, Angela, Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela.
Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela.
Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela.? It's like it never happened. Mm-hmm.
Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela. Angela.
I have one more piece of fan mail that goes with this scene, Angela, and I loved it. It's from Stacey T. and Sarah Togas brings Utah, who has worked at a pest control company since 2016, and they kill bedbugs every day. Is this some bedbugs stats? It is. Oh my gosh.
Stacey T said, quote, I absolutely love the bed bugs seen between Dwight and Jim. And I thought you might enjoy a little mini deep dive because I know way more about bed bugs than anybody wants to. I can't wait. All right. Stacey said Dwight is right that bed bugs tend to gravitate toward warmth and carbon dioxide. However, you will not typically find them in your hair. They like rough textured surfaces, like wood or a pulsed seams on mattresses, box springs, or couches. The eggs and juvenile bed bugs are very small. You cannot see them with the naked eye, and they're very good at hiding. Also, Dwight is wrong that they have a painful bite, because they actually inject a small amount of
anesthetic. So the host does not feel the bite. The painful reactions that some people get are an allergic reaction to the anesthetic, but that can take up to two weeks to appear. Also, other people don't react to their bites at all, which is why you could have two people sleeping in the same bed and one person is getting bites and then the other person isn't. Stacey said, you probably are getting bites, you just aren't allergic to them, so you're not having a reaction.
So you could be like, you know what that means? I just realized that means like, Lee and I could be sleeping in a bed bug bed, but because we're not allergic to it, we'll never know. We're just getting bitten by bed bugs all night. This is what I night. This is exactly what I was thinking. Like, as we, you know, stay in a hotel, are we just getting eaten up with bed bugs?
Maybe, but maybe you don't react to them. Here was the most interesting part of Stacey's letter. Bed bugs were almost completely eradicated from the US in the 1950s. Oh, but then there was a resurgence in the late 90s to early 2000s with a new bed bug that are extremely resistant to nearly all pesticides. Where'd it come from? Didn't say.
Because like we have a mosquito now. We have a mosquito in LA that came over on a plane. No on a cargo ship of bamboo. I heard it was on a plane from Australia. I heard it was from Japan. They were hiding in bamboo on a cargo ship from Japan. We'll get to the bottom of this, but pretty much everyone here all they can talk about is that some mosquito traveled here from across the ocean.
And now we have this mosquito infestation. Yes, there were no mosquitoes here. Yeah, none. It was so amazing. And now there is this fast multiplying little like black mosquito that came here from somewhere. I have a mosquito guy. It might be a scam.
I don't know, but there's a guy now who comes over and he puts buckets of something around our yard. The idea is that the mosquitoes are attracted to this water and then it sterilizes them so they can't reproduce. But the problem is if your neighbor doesn't also have the mosquito buckets, then they'll just go reproduce on your neighbor's yard and then fly over to you. But it's supposed to help.
But I don't know. I'm desperate. I will have a mosquito guy. I'll have the buckets. I hate the mosquitoes. Do I need the mosquito guy? Or can I just order the buckets and set them out myself? No, because he comes and he changes the stuff
in the buckets once a month. Oh. I don't know. They're someone's swore by them. Okay. A friend of mine, in their neighborhood, they all got together and they did the buckets. All right.
So we got the buckets and then we told our neighbors and I don't think anyone else got the buckets. It's just us. Give me a info. All right. Anyway, back to bedbugs. Apparently, there is not a pesticide that reliably kills bedbug eggs in a single treatment. So the best treatment options are either a professional heat treatment or a series of at least four to six chemical treatments spaced every two weeks so that you can kill the bugs every time they start to hatch.
But you'll be sterile. Not kidding. So you just throw away the mattress. I think, right? I mean, how much does all this cost? Is it cheaper than a new mattress? Could you imagine you have someone coming to your house every two weeks for how long? Six treatments of you're chemically treating your mattress,
what does that smell like? No, I don't want it. I'd rather sleep on the floor, but are the eggs in the floor now? How do you get rid of bed bugs? Stacy said they could live in a couch. I don't want to think about it. I was happy before we went out. floor, but are the eggs in the floor now? How do you get rid of bed bugs? Stacey said they could live in a couch. I don't want to think about it. I was happy before we started talking about it. I'm itchy. I was fine. I know. I'm sorry, but I found that fascinating.
Stacey, I loved that. I ate it up. Yes. Thank you, Stacey, for all of that information that's going to haunt me. Well, is springing something into Packer's beer. He's inhaler. Yeah, I looked it up in the script. I wanted to make sure what it was. And the shooting draft it said, Gabe takes out his inhaler and starts repeatedly pumping it into Packer's drink.
Gabe gets winded and takes a hit of it then goes back to emptying it into the drink. Oh, we didn't see that part. Well, it works because Packer is going to vomit into Gabe's lap, ruining his bootleg corduroyse. We got a piece of fan mail from John T. in Holy UK who said, one of the lines that has always tickled me is when Gabe says,
they don't make these cords and boot cut anymore. I laugh every time I rewatch the series, which is a lot, and I would love it if you could do a deep dive on bootleg cords. John, I'm with you. It cracked me up. What I also really loved was the camera work where they pan down. Yes. You know, Zach Woods is very tall. So those were some really long cords, but they were bootleg.
I'll have you know. John, I looked it up for you. You can get men's boot cut cords. In fact, they were labeled as being back in style. You can find them at Walmart for $36.99 and they come in a variety of colors. You can get black, coffee, khaki, wine, red, or cream white. Give them to me in cream white. I mean, I saw the picture of just these white boot cut cords and I wondered where are we
going to go in these. But yes, they're available. Speaking of telonasty, somebody's gonna get hashtag Telenasty'd. And so it begins. Yeah, buckle in everyone. Buckle in because Kathy is gonna order room service. And then she's like, uh-oh, but you know, I work out, fill my legs. Feel my leg?
Yeah, by the way, she's been putting lotion on in front of him. Stop it, Kathy. Stop it. This is it. Jim was like, okay, listen, I's been putting lotion on in front of him. I mean, stop it, Kathy. Stop it. This is it. Jim was like, okay, listen, I think I just need to say it. I am married. I'm actually very happily married. And then she does such a bitchy thing.
She goes, I'm sorry, what are you talking about? I sat at your wife's desk. I know you're married. How little do you think of me? And then Jim is really thrown. He's like, I'm sorry, I guess I read this wrong. And now he's going against all of his instincts. Yeah, right?
He's like, you know what, fine, you can stay. And then she's like, you promise you won't run to the other side of the room all night. He's like, yeah, sure, sure, we'll just watch the game. And he sits down and she snuggles up right next to him. Here it began, the fan mail flurry. Let's hear it. It goes something like this. I'm pulling from several letters.
Quote, what the hell, Jim? Yeah. You are to blame here, Jim. Uh-oh. Stand up for something, man. Put your foot down. Get this woman out of your room. And if you can't, then leave the room yourself.
And don't go back. He went down to the bar to get to right. Just stay at the bar. No kidding. I am reading it like this because there was a lot of all caps. Oh, yeah, just so you know. There's more. I cannot stand Jim in this episode. Please, please discuss this at great length, ladies. More mail. Kiana from Oregon said I never understood how this whole Kathy situation was never discussed on screen with Jim and Pam.
Did he ever tell her? And Morgan and Raleigh North Carolina said, please tell me there's a deleted scene that we don't know about. Oh, yes, there was. There was a very big scene it was deleted. It would have come after the next scene when Pam and Andy go into Daryl's office.
Yes, so Daryl is bummed about Val's boyfriend. Uh-huh. Andy and Pam go into his office, Andy's saying, play it cool, Val will come around, and Pam says, no, just go for it. And Andy says, no, Jim would tell you to play it cool. And Pam says, Jim would tell you to go for it. Yeah, so now the scene would have extended.
It's indelated scenes. It would have continued, and Pam would have said, Well, you know what? Let's call Jim and ask him. Basically, she's debating with Andy. Is Andy right? Is Jim gonna say play it cool? Or am I right? I'm his wife. Yes. I think I know my husband. So somehow by memory She knows Jim's hotel room number in Tallahassy and she puts the sunspeaker phone and Kathy answers the phone. Yeah, and Andy and Darryl and Pam are all like, huh, so let's hear it Let's call Jim You're gonna be embarrassed you think so
Okay, we'll see. He'll tell you. Hello. Hello? Hello? Hello? Hey, how are you? I'm fine.
I'm fine. I'm fine. Hello? Hello? Hey, how are you? I'm fine. You're fine. Yeah, I'm here with Andy and Darryl.
Do you know what are you and Kathy up to? Watching a game. Do you guys alone? Did everyone come up from the bar? Just being Kathy now, something's wrong with her feeding unit. Do I drop by too though? And Stanley was here. Ah!
Jim, don't do it. Or do do it. Whatever it is, this is awesome. Hey, babe, is Einstein with you? No, Einstein is not with me. Einstein is the codename we use if we're a caught in a home invasion scenario. As a parent, you think of these things.
Okay, so there's a lot of things happening here. A lot of things to unpack. Pam is weirded out. And like Kelly comes in. Kelly's having the best night of her life. So much gossip. Yes, so much is happening. Yeah. The best night of her life, basically. Okay, so this kind of started something that never got resolved. This was my complaint that I was talking about earlier, which is that you were going to see Pam get insecure
and you were also going to see everyone in the office assume something was going on between Jim and Kathy. Kelly's so excited. And so because of that, John and I were like, you have to write a scene that resolves this insecurity in Pam. You have to. So they did. And then there was another scene that we shot that was also deleted.
Jim and Pam are on the phone. It would have played a little later. Should we listen to that one? Yeah. She's still sitting right there. You know she's lying about the heating. Of course. I feel bad for her.
Really pathetic. Hmm, yes, it is. I wish I was there to see your face. You always look really cute when you're embarrassed. Okay. Ha ha ha. I love you. I'll talk to you later. Have fun with that. Love you too. I will not. Nice to hear your voice. Scranton built a million miles away, right?
So the point of that one was to show that like, Pam is on to Kathy. She is in no way insecure. And in fact, is somewhat amused by Jim's predicament. Yeah, she's like, enjoy that. And he's like, I will not. Well, you know, Warren said, if you watch the deleted scene, you can tell it doesn't play because the audience gets both halves. They get on the front end, Pam in the office trying to mask her anxiety about it.
But then on the B side, you can hear her do a complete 180 and she's totally at ease. And when they watched them, it just didn't match. And it was cut. No, I agree. It didn't really play. But by cutting it out, it kind of ends with the audience knowing that Jim ultimately spent the night with Dwight. But we don't know if Jim ever told Pam about this. And you have to remember
但接着在B面，你可以听到她来了个180度大转弯，整个人完全放松了。当他们看完这些素材时，发现根本对不上。于是就被剪掉了。不，我同意。这确实没法播。但把它剪掉之后，观众的感受就变成了吉姆最终和德怀特过夜了。但我们不知道吉姆有没有把这事告诉帕姆。而且你得记住
both Stanley and Dwight know that Kathy was in Jim's room. I mean, someone's gonna end up saying something back to the office. Like, even if this phone call never happened, people still know Kathy was in Jim's room. You know Stanley's gonna tell Phyllis. 100%. And then Phyllis is gonna tell somebody. Well, here's what happened. I told you I was at the hotel because I was gonna do the other side of my phone call dialogue.
斯坦利和德怀特都知道凯西在吉姆的房间里。我是说，总有人会把这事说回办公室。哪怕这通电话从来没发生过，大家也都知道凯西在吉姆的房间里。你知道斯坦利肯定会告诉菲yllis的。百分之百。然后菲yllis又会告诉别人。好吧，事情是这样的。我跟你说过我在酒店，因为我要去录我那通电话台词的另一半。
Right. Well, I was just watching all of this play out. Like all of the way Jim was playing it, the way Kathy was playing it. And John and I were so in our heads about this. We just were so nervous about how Jim was gonna come across and how the relationship was gonna come across. And we had one of those moments
对。好吧，我当时只是在旁边看着这一切发展。就像吉姆当时的应对方式，凯西的应对方式。我和约翰当时为了这件事真的想得太多了。我们只是对吉姆会怎么表现、这段关系会怎么呈现感到非常焦虑。我们经历了一个那样的时刻
that had not happened in a very long time. I know it became, I mean, these moments when they did happen, it was like screech, like all filming stopped. Yeah, they kind of shut down the set and we had this huge discussion with Warren and Holstead and Brian Paul got in on it. John and I were there. And that is kind of in the moment they crafted that second phone call to show that Pam was going to be okay. Well, Jim and Pam are the heart of the show. We've known that for a long time. Steven Merchant said that from day one. So you cannot lose hope in Jim and Pam.
已经很久没有发生过了。我知道后来，我是说，当这些时刻真的发生时，就像是发出刺耳的急刹车，所有的拍摄都停了下来。对，他们基本上把片场停工了，我们和沃伦、霍尔斯特德进行了长篇大论的讨论，布赖恩·保尔也加入了进来。我和约翰都在场。那就是他们在那个当下构思出第二通电话的原因，以此来表明帕姆会没事的。好吧，吉姆和帕姆是这部剧的核心。我们很早就知道了。史蒂芬·莫昌特从第一天起就这么说。所以你绝对不能对吉姆和帕姆失去希望。
No. Open a frame. Open a frame. That's right. I brought it for that. I brought it back. Ah, here was another thing that kind of drove me crazy. And I brought this up in our discussions.
不。打开一帧。打开一帧。没错。我是为了这个才拿来的。我又把它拿回来了。啊，这里还有另一件事让我快疯了。我在我们的讨论中也提到了这一点。
And it drove people crazy in the audience, too, which is that Kathy is not Jim superior. She's not even a permanent employee at Dunderclund. So what is driving Jim's inability to speak up? You know? Yeah. I mean, some people pointed out that they did think it was in character for him because Jim does tend to kind of like freeze up in moments like this. But I don't know why couldn't Jim just do everything we've been saying. Just kick her out, stay down in the bar. You know Warren said something that I hadn't thought of, which was that the series of events with Kathy, like the heater going on the fritz and her taking a shower, all of these different moments,
观众们也觉得这事让人抓狂，那就是凯西并不是吉姆的上司。她甚至不是邓德米夫林的正式员工。那到底是什么导致吉姆无法开口说话呢？你知道吗？对。我是说，有些人指出，他们确实觉得这很符合他人设，因为吉姆在遇到这种时刻时往往会有点像冻僵了一样。但我不知道为什么吉姆就不能做我们刚才说过的那些事。直接把她赶出去，待在楼下酒吧里。你知道沃伦说过一件事我之前没想到，那就是关于凯西的一系列事件，比如暖气故障啦，她去洗澡啦，所有这些不同的时刻，
they were trying to build this feeling of Jim feeling trapped, like Kathy has trapped him in his own room. And I kind of felt that tension. It just kept heightening and heightening and he started feeling more and more trapped. Warren and Halstead also shared with us that in an earlier draft of the episode, Kathy initially comes into Jim's room crying
他们试图营造出一种吉姆感到被困住的感觉，就像凯西把他困在自己的房间里一样。我确实能感受到那种紧张感。这种感觉不断升级、加剧，他开始感到越来越绝望、越来越被动。沃伦和霍尔斯特德还跟我们分享过，在这集较早的剧本草稿中，凯西最初是哭着走进吉姆房间的
about her boyfriend. I remember this. Yeah. She had trouble with her boyfriend and she starts reading Jim, her boyfriend's text messages off of her phone, to get his opinion on how to handle it. You guys remember, I brought up a deleted talking head-of-wall back that she had this boyfriend named Doug, right? Yes. remember I brought up a deleted talking head a while back that she had this boyfriend named Doug, right? Yes. But then all of that ended up getting scrapped. That makes more sense for me. If a Cathy's trying to play Jim, that she would come in with like this shitty boyfriend
为了她的男朋友。我记得这个。对。她和男朋友出了问题，然后她开始把她手机上男朋友发的信息读给吉姆听，想听听他对该如何处理这件事的看法。你们还记得吗，我之前提过一个被删掉的访谈花絮，提到她有个男朋友叫道格，对吧？是的。记得我前段时间提过一个被删掉的访谈花絮，她有个男朋友叫道格，对吧？是的。但后来所有这些全都被砍掉了。这样对我来说更合理。如果凯西是想套路吉姆，她编出一个这么烂的男友
story and be the damsel and distress in a way that's where Jim might feel like, oh, maybe I should talk her through this. Yes. And then she turns the tables on him. Looking back, maybe that would have made more sense. I don't know. I mean, here's my question. Do you think they should have kept
故事，以一种受惊少女的姿态出现，吉姆可能就会觉得，噢，也许我该开导开导她。是的。然后她再反客为主。回过头来看，也许那样会更合理。我不知道。我是说，我的问题是：你觉得他们当时应该保留
all the deleted phone call stuff between Jim and Pam? It bothers me that all of this went down and Pam has no awareness of it and that the audience is left wondering. Well, I agree with Warren that the way the two phone calls, like happened, Pam does this 180 that didn't quite make sense. I agree. So I agree with that, but you know what I would have liked.
所有吉姆和帕姆之间被删掉的电话内容吗？让我困扰的是，发生了这么多事，帕姆却一无所知，而且还让观众去猜。好吧，我同意沃伦的看法，就是这两通电话发生的方式，帕姆来了个180度大转弯，这确实有点说不通。我同意。所以我同意这一点，但你知道我希望看到的是什么吗？
Do you remember in early seasons of the show when Jim would leave Pam messages or she would leave him? I thought of that too. Yeah, and then you would see a montage of the end of their evening. Maybe it's Pam cleaning out baby bottles or whatever and she's listening to Jim's message. Maybe she missed his call because she was doing bedtime or something and he's like, you would not believe the night I had. It was so crazy. Kathy came in my room. She wouldn't leave. I had to pretend there were bedbugs and get Dwight to spray her out of the room. You know, or something and then you see Pam laughing.
你还记得剧集早期的时候，吉姆会给帕姆留留言，或者她会给他留留言吗？我也想到了。对，然后你会看到他们当晚结束时的蒙太奇。也许是帕姆在清洗奶瓶之类的，然后她听着吉姆的留言。也许她因为在哄孩子睡觉之类的错过了他的电话，而他说，你绝对不敢相信我今晚遇到了什么事。太疯狂了。凯西进了我的房间。她就是不肯走。我不得不假装有臭虫，让德怀特把她喷出房间。你知道，诸如此类，然后你就会看到帕姆在笑。
Yes. And then Pam leaves a message like, Hey, I missed your call. You're probably dealing with Dwight and bedbugs right now. Yeah, but that's hilarious. Also, do I need to punch her or something? You know, like, yes. Something that Jim confided in Pam that shows the audience set that lives in the canon
是的。然后帕姆留了一条语音说，嘿，我错过你的电话了。你现在大概正在应付德怀特和臭虫吧。对，但这太搞笑了。还有，我是不是需要去揍她一顿什么的？你知道，就像是，是的。吉姆向帕姆倾诉了一些事，这向观众证明了这些内容是属于正剧设定的一部分
of the show. Yes, I thought of that same like dueling voicemail thing as well. Or even just a phone call at the end of the night. You know, I know that they really wanted to end this episode on Jim and Dwight and kind of showing that bond between the two of them, but I just, I wish that we would have had more resolution
这部剧的。是的，我也想到了那种针锋相对的语音信箱。或者甚至只是在当晚结束时打个电话。你知道，我知道他们真的很想以吉姆和德怀特作为这集的结尾，以此来展现他们两人之间的那种羁绊，但我只是，我希望我们能对
on this Jim and Pam thing. For Pam. And for Jim. Yeah. And for the audience. Yeah. I do think it's a hilarious episode and a great ending and there were so many funny beats, but I agree with you.
吉姆和帕姆这件事有更多的交代。为了帕姆。也为了吉姆。对。为了观众。对。我确实觉得这是一集非常搞笑、结局很棒的剧集，里面有好多搞笑的节奏，但我同意你的看法。
As this episode comes to a close, Ryan is going to learn that basically Aaron wants him to be her roommate, who knows maybe in six months they could hook up and he's like six months. Yeah. he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like,
当这集接近尾声时，瑞安得知基本上艾伦希望他做她的室友，谁知道呢，也许六个月后他们就能好上了，而他的反应是，六个月。对。他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，
he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like,
他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，
he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, he's like, by virtue of default, I think, because Packer got sick. And Nelly is like, what am I thinking? What am I thinking right now? Read my mind. Dwight's like, seven, one, one, nine. She's like, not numbers. I loved it when she said that. That
他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，他就像是，因祸得福吧，我想，因为派克生病了。奈莉就说，我在想什么？我现在在想什么？读我的心。德怀特说，七，一，一，九。她说，不是数字。我太喜欢她这么说了。那
was my horrible British accent. And then she's like, do it again. He's like, again, I'm just getting numbers. I have a really fun piece of mail from Shannon M. and Manchester Kentucky who said, I noticed that when Dwight is at the bar with Nelly and he's trying to read her mind, he just keeps coming up with numbers. In the next scene, back at Dunder Mifflin,
是我的糟糕英国口音。然后她说，再来一次。他说，再来一次，我脑子里还是只有数字。我有一封来自肯塔基州曼彻斯特的香农·M的非常有趣的信件，她说，我注意到当德怀特和奈莉在酒吧里，他试图读懂她的心思时，他脑子里一直冒出数字。在下一场戏中，回到邓德米夫林，
Angela is reciting numbers. Okay. I thought about this too, Janet. You did? I did, and you know what? I wrote down. I said, isn't it interesting that Dwight said three of the numbers that Angela reads out loud?
安吉拉在背诵数字。好吧。我也想过这个，珍妮特。你也有？我有，你知道吗？我写下来了。我说，难道不有趣吗，德怀特说出的数字里有三个正是安吉拉大声念出来的？
Yes, because Angela reads 1434967 and Dwight says 7-1-1-9. Shannon wondered if this was just a little nod to the fact that the people who are really connected are Dwight and Angela and that's why he's receiving numbers. I loved it. I think it was a coincidence but I thought it was really sweet. Also Becca R from Ohio wanted to know if this mind reading scene was a call back to Catherine Tate's time on Dr. Who. Oh, cute. So a lot of people saw a lot of meaning in this scene. Dwight is ultimately going to decide that this is not how we wants to get ahead. You know, yeah, I like it.
是的，因为安吉拉念的是1434967，而德怀特说的是7-1-1-9。香农想知道这是否只是一个小小的致意，暗示真正心有灵犀的人其实是德怀特和安吉拉，这就是为什么他能接收到数字。我太喜欢了。我觉得这只是个巧合，但我认为这真的很甜。另外，来自俄亥俄州的贝卡·R想知道这场读心术的戏是不是在致敬凯瑟琳·塔特在《神秘博士》里的演出。噢，太可爱了。所以很多人在这场戏里看到了很多深意。德怀特最终决定这不是他想要的出人头地的方式。你知道，对，我喜欢这样。
He has integrity. He does. And he gives her his room key, but then scratches out the bar, you know, the magnetic strip on the back. Yeah. So she can't use it. Yeah, Jim is going on the back. Yeah. So she can't use it. Yeah, Jim is gonna finally grow a set
他有原则。他确实有。他把房门钥匙给了她，但在背面把酒吧，你知道，把背面的磁条给刮掉了。对。所以她用不了。对，吉姆终于要硬气一回了
and he comes out of the bathroom and finds Kathy under his covers without a bath robe on and he just tells her to leave. He finally says get out, but I guess he's also called Dwight because as he's yelling get out, Dwight comes in with like a fumigation mask and like cleaning chemicals.
他从浴室出来，发现凯西穿着没穿浴袍就钻进了他的被窝，他直接叫她离开。他最后说滚出去，但我想他也叫了德怀特，因为就在他大喊滚出去的时候，德怀特拿着类似烟熏消毒面罩和清洁化学品进来了。
They basically spray her out of the room. I just thought, I felt like Kathy's behavior was horrible, but I'm like, this is such a s***y way to get her to leave the room. I mean, really, it shouldn't have come to this. I know. I know. I know. So now Dwight has sprayed chemicals all over Jim's room. So where are they going to go? They're going to both go now to Dwight's room
他们基本上是用喷剂把她熏出了房间。我只是觉得，我觉得凯西的行为太糟糕了，但我想，用这种恶心的方式把她赶出房间也太那啥了。我是说，真的，本不该闹到这一步的。我知道。我知道。我知道。所以现在德怀特把化学药剂喷遍了吉姆的房间。那他们要去哪里？他们现在都要去德怀特的房间了
with the desserts that Kathy ordered. Yes. And they're having this really nice time eating their desserts and bed together. And Nelly is going to try to get into Dwight's room, but it doesn't work. Yeah. In the shooting draft, there was an extra piece of dialogue where Dwight and Jim kind of acknowledged that they had to dodge these women because Dwight goes bed bugs, huh?
带着凯西点的甜点。是的。他们在床上一起开开心心地吃着甜点。奈莉想进德怀特的房间，但没成功。对。在拍摄剧本中，还有一段额外的对话，德怀特和吉姆承认他们不得不躲着这些女人，因为德怀特说：有臭虫，哈？
And Jim's like, yep. And then Jim says, is that Nelly? And he's like, nope. You know what I mean? That's cute. That's cute. Yes, I know I said that maybe the final scene could have been a Jim and Pam thing, but I do actually love how this episode ends with Jim and Dwight. And Warren said that when he thinks of this episode, the image that comes to mind is
然后吉姆说：对。接着吉姆说：那是奈莉吗？他回答：不是。你知道我的意思吗？太可爱了。太可爱了。是的，我知道我之前说过也许最后一集可以安排一个吉姆和帕姆的桥段，但我其实真的很喜欢这集以吉姆和德怀特收尾。沃伦说过，当他想起这一集时，脑海中浮现的画面是
John and Raine eating dessert on the bed together. And he said, I know that's not what the episode is about, but he loved that final image so much that when he was on set, he took a picture of it, which he said is something he almost never did. But it is like, I love those moments when Jim and Dwight bond for a second, like that they're deep down their friends, right? Yeah. It was that classic Dwight Jim, like episode where they always used to have adventures together. They'd go on the road with Michael and I did love that. You know, it reminds me, you know, I've been fostering kittens again.
约翰和雷恩一起在床上吃甜点。他说，我知道这一集讲的不是这个，但他太喜欢那个最后的画面了，以至于他在片场时拍了张照片，他说这是他几乎从未做过的事。但这就是，我太喜欢那些吉姆和德怀特心有灵犀一瞬间的时刻了，就好像他们骨子里其实是朋友，对吧？对。这就是那种经典的德怀特与吉姆式的情节，他们以前总是一起经历各种冒险。他们和迈克尔一起出差，我真的很喜欢那样。你知道，这让我想起，你知道，我最近又在寄养小猫了。
And what about this remind you of the kittens? What reminds me about it is like, you know, sunny gets really cranky when the kittens are trying to play with him. But then every once in a while, he'll like engage them or he'll like sniff noses with them or give them like a friendly little pat. And that's what it reminded me of. Like these two cats that are always going at it, but then all of a sudden you walk in a room and they're snuggling and you're like, oh, oh, they do love each other for five minutes. Yes. I mean, I feel like that's something Oscar would have said at the beginning. And yeah, I'm sure I would have been like, okay, unbelievable.
这怎么就让你想起小猫了？让我想起的是，你知道的，桑尼在小猫试图跟他玩时会变得非常暴躁。但接着每隔一段时间，他就会跟它们互动一下，或者跟它们碰碰鼻子，或者给它们一个友好的小拍拍。这就是让我想起的原因。就像这两只猫总是打得不可开交，但突然之间你走进房间，发现它们依偎在一起，然后你会想，噢，噢，它们其实还是爱彼此五分钟的。是的。我是说，我觉得这正是奥斯卡在开头会说的那种话。而且是的，我敢肯定我当时的反应会是，好吧，简直难以置信。
Well, the late night jam work session is officially over. Everyone is leaving even though Andy's like, wait, I have a cool down session. I got decaf coffee, Romaine Michelle's high school reunion. Everyone just wants to go home, except Kelly. Thanks, Andy for an amazing night. Exactly. And Darrell and Val have a moment. Val says, look, I'm sorry.
好吧，深夜加班工作正式结束了。大家都准备离开，尽管安迪还在说：等等，我还有个放松环节。我弄到了低因咖啡，罗曼·米歇尔的高中同学聚会。每个人都只想回家，除了凯莉。谢谢安迪带给我们美妙的一夜。没错。而达里尔和瓦尔也有了一个时刻。瓦尔说：听着，我很抱歉。
Can we just never talk about this again? And Darrell says, sure. And by the way, I don't think the idea of a CIS ridiculous. Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. And Val kind of smiles. Mm-hmm. I loved it. I loved it.
我们能不能就当这事从没发生过？达里尔说：当然。顺便说一句，我觉得那个CIS的想法其实并没那么荒谬。点，点，点，点，点。瓦尔微微一笑。嗯哼。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
Before we wrap up this episode, I have to share one thing from my digital clutter. Okay. When we were filming this episode, we received an all-cast email from Greg Daniels. The subject said, congratulations. And when you opened the email, it said, on your sag nomination for best comedy ensemble, again, exclamation point. You guys are so brilliant, it is so well deserved. I always loved our emails from Greg.
在结束这一集之前，我必须分享一个我数字杂物里的东西。好吧。当我们拍摄这一集时，我们收到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯发给全体演员的邮件。主题写着：恭喜。当你打开邮件时，上面写着：祝贺你们再次获得最佳喜剧群戏的演员工会奖提名，惊叹号。你们太才华横溢了，这是实至名归。我总是很喜欢格雷格发给我们的邮件。
It just took me back. It took me back. What a fun group of people we got to work with. What a fun show we got to do. We laughed so much. We laughed so much. Guess what? What?
这把我带回了过去。把我带回了过去。我们共事的真是一群有趣的人。我们拍了一部多么有趣的剧啊。我们笑了那么多。我们笑了那么多。你猜怎么着？什么？
My mood has shifted. Yay! We did it. We laughed so much. Guess what? What? My mood has shifted. Yay! We did it. We did it! You guys, we hope you have a fantastic week. Huge thank you to Warren and Halstead for sharing their memories about writing this episode. And also to Steve Burgess,
我的情绪转变了。耶！我们做到了。我们笑了那么多。你猜怎么着？什么？我的情绪转变了。耶！我们做到了。我们做到了！大家，希望你们有个愉快的一周。非常感谢沃伦和霍尔斯特德分享他们创作这一集的记忆。还要感谢史蒂芬·伯格斯，
who gave me a bunch of great behind-the-scenes production info. And to all of you for sending in awesome questions and comments and observations, we love you guys, and we'll see you next week. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy
他为我提供了一堆精彩的幕后制作信息。还要感谢所有发来精彩问题、评论和观察的你们，我们爱你们，我们下周见。回头见！感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲
and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。你这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。